De nombreuses espèces de dinosaures portaient des plumes ?
À l’heure actuelle, on connait une vingtaine d’espèces de dinosaures à plumes.
Principalement grâce aux découvertes réalisées à partir de 1996
dans le Nord-Est de la Chine, dans une région que l’on appelle le Liaoning.
Les découvertes réalisées dans le Liaoning,
donc dans des terrains datant
principalement d’environ 125 millions d’années,
ont permis de préciser que, potentiellement,
l’ensemble des dinosaures carnivores,
donc qui appartiennent à une lignée que l’on appelle les Théropodes,
étaient recouverts de plumes plus ou moins élaborées.
Les oiseaux actuels font partie, en fait sont une branche,
de ce groupe des dinosaures Théropodes.
En 2013, nous avons découvert en Sibérie,
un petit dinosaure qui appartient à un groupe
que l’on appelle les dinosaures Ornithischiens.
Et il avait des plumes !
Et il avait des structures rappelant les plumes primitives
que l’on retrouve chez les Théropodes.
Donc cela veut dire que, peut-être, les structures de plumes
ou de protoplumes existaient potentiellement chez tous les dinosaures.
Alors qu’est-ce qu’on appelle une structure primitive de plume, une protoplume ?
On pourrait définir une protoplume
comme une plume ne servant pas au vol.
Et elle sert à quoi ?
Alors, la première fonction d’une plume,
c’est probablement d’isoler thermiquement le corps.
Les oiseaux, et probablement tous les dinosaures Théropodes,
étaient des animaux à sang chaud.
Donc ils produisaient leur propre chaleur,
mais, comme dans une maison,
cela ne sert à rien d’avoir une bonne chaudière
si on n’a pas un toit bien isolé.
Donc les plumes, le duvet, servaient à isoler
le corps thermiquement. Ça, c’est une première fonction.
Une seconde fonction des plumes, c’est « faire joli ».
Donc les plumes, encore à l’heure actuelle chez les oiseaux,
ont un rôle très important au cours de la parade nuptiale.
C’est probablement le cas chez les dinosaures également.
Et la troisième fonction, enfin, la dernière, c’est le vol.
Donc, les plumes de vol sont apparues
en fin d’évolution de ces structures.
On va retrouver ces plumes de vol
chez des dinosaures comme les Microraptors.
Les Microraptors, ce ne sont pas des oiseaux,
et ce sont de très proches cousins
du célèbre Velociraptor de Steven Spielberg.
Donc, on sait aujourd’hui que l’histoire de la plume a commencé
il y a au moins 160 millions d’années ?
L’histoire de la plume a commencé probablement beaucoup plus tôt,
il y a au moins 210 à 220 millions d’années.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu’on connaît les plumes
chez les dinosaures Théropodes
et on connaît également le Kulindadromeus
qui est un dinosaure Ornithischien primitif
avec des structures ressemblant à des plumes.
Si l’on retrouve les plumes dans ces 2 groupes,
cela veut dire que leur ancêtre commun,
qui a vécu à la fin du Trias,  il y a environ 220 millions d’années,
avait probablement des plumes, également.